Nice. Let's start reward though. We
should have a reward. I got to, I got
out of this month.
We're going to present you with the belt
is we're going to get that done while
they're on the stack of weed.
I would like to say
hope fiction bottom my Instagram
for more details. Okay. Okay.
Actually let's present the the pulp fit.
It's more like creep show werewolf
that lives under the stairs.
Creep shows they perfect.
That is the perfect no goddamn crate.
That's the creative creep show. There's
more nightmares. I felt so bad. Okay.
I would like ladies and gentlemen,
we people to present this belt.
Thank you very much. Ultimately
make you crazy. By the way.
The fact that we actually
did this was nuts.
Nuts and I would like
to say on behalf of me,
one of the three non winners,
I won't say losers of the sober October
of fitness challenge. Joe Rogan,
much like Jesus before him where there
was nothing and then there was winning
Joe Rogan.
You have achieved the champion of
sober October physical challenge.
I ours your fair presents you Joe Rogan.
This belt saying,
you are the champion of sober October.
I just want to stay for the record.
I was most impressed by you and then
if you had been exercising as long as I
probably would have died trying to
defeat you, great job drug like Thompson.
Yes sir. I was not impressed. Come
on over the belt. It's already on.
I'll just say this. I was a Joe. You
showed us definitely what time it was.
It was all about second place
and you definitely got that.
So congratulations to you Ari.
But Joe, uh, your in better I,
here's a huge shocker. You're in
better shape than the three of us.
I think that had a factor.
There was certainly a part of it.
How much energy could put out.
We all put in though, man,
we all worked our ass off.
But it's ultimately it's about TRT.
Is that tight enough or not even
like an advertisement? Trt. Fuck.
At some point we're like, hey,
really does go to show you that steroids
can help it. Athletic Challenges.
This is why it's illegal.